so let's get more now on Donald Trump's
troubles which could see him knocked out
of the u.s. election campaign i'm joined
by the political scientist Professor
Peter Mathews who's in Long Beach
California professor Matthews thanks
very much for joining us and any other
politician who said what Donald Trump
has said would be toast by now and with
this new claim that Hillary Clinton
founded Islamic state has he done the
seemingly impossible and gone too far
even for him he's gone very very far
with that claim and he's down to thirty
five percent of vote Hillary's got about
forty three percent in most of the polls
so this is showing its telling him he's
got a ten-foot percent disadvantage now
he's dropped considerably since the two
conventions were over because if
somebody's outrageous statements so what
has happened also the Republican
leadership for example gym so I Paul
Ryan and and the other leaders he's
refusing Donald was refusing to endorse
Paul Ryan in his reelection bid on
august nine a Paul Ryan is the second
most powerful person in the US
government speaker of the house so Trump
is just doing things soon unorthodox and
in a manner in which may not be able to
recover from these things but you know
we're not Trump is Trump and I'm also
considering this may be as sort of a
hidden vote that Hillary Clinton needs
to work think about a hidden vote in
which many of the people in the polls
say that they will not vote for Trump
their voting for Hillary because they're
kind of a shame embarrassed to say
they're supporting Trump and yet when
they go into that polling booth and
they're in their privacy they could
actually catch the vote for Trump
Trump's always outperform his polls by a
few percentage points so that's
something to consider as well but some
of these statement he's making it is so
outrageous he's plummeted in the last
few days since the Democratic convention
was over those comments about mr. Khan
and others in the son of mr. Khan who
was killed in combat it was just
outrageous than that the Republican
leadership of trying distances to
distance themselves are trying to get
him to wise up and behave as a real
candidate so it'll be interesting what
happens you mentioned Republicans
increasingly distancing themselves from
him how much does actually hurt his
campaign in reality among voters on the
ground you said that some people silent
voters might go in and vote for him he's
obviously playing already to his strong
fan base but how it doesn't hurt him
amongst those people does it him saying
these things no it doesn't it doesn't
hurt him among his strong fan base
because they're convinced
the man who's the outsider who can
really straighten things out because
they're so fed up with their lives
having lost jobs jobs sourcing they
blamed the American elite but both
parties for encouraging free trade
without fair trade and you saw the
brexit vote in Britain there's a
similarity here people were fed up and
there was no prediction that Rex it
would pass and yet it did because of the
hidden vote and the fermentation of
discontent and we had that here in
America a lot of people's lives have not
gotten better since the recession was so
so called over they haven't the jobs
they've gotten to thurs those jobs or
lower paying jobs on the job that they
had when they were laid off so there's a
lot of problems here with the economy if
Trump would just stick to the economy
and leave the social issues alone he'd
do a lot better but Hillary's actually
doing hoping it does the opposite she
wants to fight him on the social issues
and because most Americans are very
progressive and liberal on social issues
so Trump needs to I mean I'm not gonna
give him advice but this is the way I
see it that he could actually look for
this whole thing and yet he's got that
hidden vote he's got those loyal
supporters the fed up though they I did
it the fact that he's the agent of
change he can use that relate to
catapult himself forward because he can
say I'm the change agent I'm not the
politician I was never in politics and
you can keep haranguing the leadership
of both parties is being corrupt I've
been taking money away from big banks
and corporations and he says like I'm my
own business man and I have my own
funding and all he does take money now
from some wealthy people's to for
campaigns by the way he raised 80
million dollars this month in july 80
million to Hillary side of 90 million so
he's actually narrowed the gap and
fundraising which means with that kind
of money can come up a lot of negative
campaigning in september-october against
Hillary and how she is think sorry how
will the Democrats be reacting to these
sort of latest outburst well they
secretly be quite pleased that he's
doing this because it opens up the
center ground of people who who aren't
avid Trump fans but maybe are on his
side but the more he says these things
about social issues they'll veer more
towards clinton yes the democrats are
just loving it in private and in fact
Hillary's reached out to many
Republicans and some of them responded
meg whitman the former candidate around
for governor in california
multi-millionaire who was the old
Packard executive she's now endorsed
Hillary CCA's you're gonna vote for
inches when we raise funds burglary
she's a Republican and many other
Republicans in leadership positions have
actually said they're supporting Hillary
Clinton and she's reaching out at them
sound opens up the center it opens up a
cross-section of voters and donors
especially and nevertheless I think that
the reason Hillary is doing well enough
at forty-three percent is biggest Trump
is doing so pearly any other candidate
would be tough for her to beat at this
point but let's face it only two major
candidates in the race although they are
the two other ones that are not getting
much publicity Jill Stein and gary
johnson Jill Stein the Green Party
counties drawing about 33 half percent
right now and Gary Jones about 9%
actually the libertarian and what's
happened with the Bernie people as many
of them have gone off to form what
they're calling it brand new Congress
they're working on having a new Congress
in 2018 of progressives running a
campaign like Bernie Sanders but without
corporate money for doing things like
single-payer health care reducing gap in
rich and poor brand new Congress with
the energy of the burning people have
gone so those Bernie voters may not
really be focusing too much on
supporting Hillary that's about thirty
percent of burning voters so they would
not vote for Hillary but in the end LED
seats in the end of the polling booth
when it comes down to people saying our
main choices are Trump or Hillary and
they may actually go for Hillary so
we'll see what happens in that case be
very interesting election never see
anything like this in my many many years
of analyzing these kinds of elections
remarkable watching it closely on this
side of the pond Professor Peter Mathews
thank you very much for your time